I'm ready which button is ready already
a 4x a okay god she's confusing all
right I got it
well ours kill you everything those
aren't flowers oh you're right plagues
it's been so long the sand is bad oh I
see what you're saying about the sand
being bad I'm not killing you why would
I kill you don't over at the end more
great it's so comfortable I get some
food from the Sun Oh do we all have to
complete it yeah yes I mean yes okay are
those vines on the top gonna kill me
no I knocked on top your foot okay okay
okay advice don't jump there okay you're
fine you can just run market and are
suffering
I gotta end you know we have to do it
god damn I don't remember this game
being this hard well we are it's already
in the second world so this is like a
learning curve kind of it expects you to
me ever again
right of course I mean I'm sorry
like this you're timing I'm doing it yes
oh god you guys want me to end it I feel
bad
I'll give Ethan what just happened
it's a recount is all our death there's
a sneaky secret off of this one we gotta
find the C keys the what Ziggy secret
okay guys I don't know what this is all
about but tempers happen here
Oh wind wind winds what happen oh
there's a window [ __ ] it's fine played
with you do not okay there's wind I also
think there's a button underneath the
sand that fires a gun I'm gonna test
that theory there's no there's not a
[Laughter]
drop down drop down drop down to the
right of that you see what I'm talking
about okay never mind I sure do
the inhale yeah I'm gonna try to get
this down here is it down here oh [ __ ]
whoa so crazy if you keep making good
the same thing over this boy's nuts it
shoots that but it opens the path on the
bottom left you guys see that okay yeah
I got that I got that all right watch
out gun
okay wait what Howard how are you
supposed to get in there though I think
there's probably ground on the bottom
maybe it's the same that kills you on
the bottle buddy okay yeah how do you do
that it's opening I bet we have to come
back with it just lets me back up there
I don't want to do that hey we got to
come back with a coin so we have to come
back with a coin we'll get it later
dammit I got in here I'm so cool you
want to do this I know how to complete
it alright yeah wait for it alright I
wish you hadn't jumped into my feet yeah
me too alright I hate it maybe we should
wait
[Laughter]
he had it that's so right yeah I know I
know I'm a dick I agree you're right
Wade is right yeah world two three Ethan
this is your world
yeah my world this is your world this is
look this just screams Ethan into my ear
hole alright alright you do that you
like floated far me yeah that's the way
that you want to do that but back okay
but it's possible
yeah I'm gonna try it weights way up
here huh
oh there's a button oh okay I understand
hey I made it guys I made it oh yeah
holy [ __ ] yeah you have to oh [ __ ] guys
oh [ __ ] it's [ __ ] and I'm gonna try to
don't you [ __ ] dare Wade you crouch
alright you got to jump then dive
there's a color change of your body your
body goes lighter when you're a peak of
your - the swinging things - jump
chiming it was just luck you need to go
all the way up and - all the way up and
- like jump and then - at the end of
your jump to make it to the cactus - Oh
walk on that sand down there no no I
think so wait bring me okay the weather
up here is frightful it is
is so delightful now I can't do either
way [ __ ] Bob we broke it no we didn't I
think said don't worry about it
oh come on - whoa yeah but you don't
need to on that that's crazy
Wow okay I'm the one who sucks beeping
it if you jump on my head and kill me I
will never move you wait you should not
stand there kill you no I can't make it
up I've ducked down you can't kill me is
that true yes that's true
do sources confirm yeah sources confirm
yeah that jump you know that jump down
over those huh that's very impressive
I'm here then I gotta get kill me Bob no
you had the right strap from the get-go
I think I just lucked out the timing
because I could not get oh boy oh okay
why is it so my god I don't know what
that means but it's not good okay watch
out for that oh no no you're so you're
you're so right
[Music]
don't understand a flying cat about try
and beat it no I got this okay cuz I got
to the finish and then I died so I'm
satisfied here what what oh no there'd
be a little I if it was a secret honest
yes you good you guys good
you guys go yeah bye let's get you out
of here it's all good guys guys it's all
good you guys are worrying over nothing
that wasn't that many thirty and I'm too
bad I could work good work good work
teamwork yeah we still have a coin we
need that coin this is gonna be a coin
level this field coiny that wasn't it
supposed to go up I think we have right
okay that's gotta be wave you gotta get
out of the way man okay see ya
I don't know where to go you would so
what do we have we decided how we're
doing someone go under the thing I open
the door see the thing below you the
stone light yeah Wow it pushes you okay
so you do have to go quickly okay I
believe in you guys all right
how the [ __ ] are we supposed to get out
like this wait you stopped the coin
correct all right how do I know that do
you see the coin down there yeah it's
not down there no okay is it possible
guys you guys are doing died more times
to [ __ ] wade stepping on my head
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
jumped over it
I will admit wave jumped over it so I
guess you can't jump through the middle
there maybe I've led you astray in fact
I don't really remember what I did you
want to stand this torment yes no no I
could do this first part now I just
can't do the [ __ ] rest of this did I
lead people astray is what of this I'm
curious
Oh God
screaming on the button of under it
[Laughter]
you could have just ducked in that
corner and ducked and that would have
worked as well so we gotta go to do we
got a gold coin yeah mark so you go
thingy and I'll go in the thing hole
okay whatever
Oh go for it I don't have the coin that
easy come on [ __ ] [ __ ] wait can I can I
open this thing and yeah yeah come in
here wait come in the hole Wade I've got
an X in my spot how do we you
[ __ ]
you've got a coin by coin another coin
John it's a coin with an X on end right
how do you place it that's it's not
supposed to have it actually X is bad
what uh the X means you don't have it
did we not get the goddamn coin no maybe
we have the wrong point
wrong coin maybe there's like maybe this
is coins for another level and that we
have to find a different coin for this
level I don't [ __ ] know I'm out of
here
yeah let's say that's God right quick
oh that one so chad is saying this one
it's a gold coin but we got a silver
coin oh yeah we did get a silver look
okay yeah all right so new beginnings
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay can walk on it but just not do that
oh I see I see I see
oh god oh [ __ ] okay well you wait your
turn wait it's only just now teaching
you about the the double jump oh here I
opened it guys I opened it wait hang on
it got a cool-down oh no it's okay
I can't slide to those dm's oh nasty
hold on go for it okay
it's [ __ ] watch a master all right
master hang on watch a master easy that
was really good with not me wait I do
yeah what we do he dashed through this
hole like a goddamn genius I don't know
how that just go ahead wait I just don't
trust you either that's all why don't
you trust me I mean I made it
I murdered the vibe is that we
you said no I said you murdered feet a
lot a lot nice thank you thank you
why is this a tutorial now like could
you get through the whole game without
doing these moves up to this point no
you just - don't jump after just - at
the peak - left - and go left - left or
a trigger also so is their timing - this
way - just as soon as you line up with
that hole you - need you just - right
off it okay yeah I was that doesn't work
wait you're a [ __ ] liar I do saw me
do it you can't touch the wall you have
to slightly - oh this is the slide I
mean I jumped and slid but you know I
don't think I think you have to jump I
thought you meant that you didn't have
you can do it the wall if you hold down
the slide you'll slide when you get to
that point now not me now but
people don't [ __ ] wait their turns
around here what is this occasionally
I'm waiting for [ __ ] to happen I thought
okay a bob ever reason I thought you
were Ethan and I just didn't care I
always loved how markets through based
on his first try these like way let me
show you how you guys getting me like
this is not fair oh my god guys this
time I'm the one I'm bursting into
flames or something go ahead go ahead
[Laughter]
[Applause]
mark okay so that is the move I didn't
know if that was the move or not oh it's
the move all right I'll be button boy
I'll be waits patiently below there's a
button in there I thought I
I would have I would have stayed I feel
like that guy who's along for the
journey but isn't actually I deserve
this
I deserve this and I deserve better than
what
[Laughter]
that's so weird are you taking the hard
way don't you
[Laughter]
why is my judge not peeking anymore
belly flop into spikes oh my god mark on
my screen full speed [ __ ] you're just
loading ok I'm cooling down cooling down
we can end it I don't have to we can end
it I'm not thank you I helped the button
is this the last level in this world not
in clothes ok that one looks gold that
looks very cool
oh Jesus okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's just if you just normal bounce
bounce it's it's not so bad too much
guys hey hi I have an idea
oh there mark I bounced up there you're
welcome you can just you can just Oh
hey hey look I'm here
hey okay watch out with the spikes up
there they're very deadly
sonic I think we have to jump off the
boulder and go left to get to that key
you might be right let me try come back
no yeah you gotta do that oh it's way up
top we're trying to get to the coin on
the Left problem you're going the exact
opposite way over there I will let you
do all right
yeah that's good good move no I do not
see how you would do that wait I have an
idea let me let me yeah yeah I haven't I
so have an idea you see do you guys
actually see her you just all the jump
jump jump yeah I think if I no no no no
if he needs your kind of help
holy [ __ ] coin can I get out of it can I
get out okay guys thank you you're
welcome guys I have bark you could do it
[ __ ] I say it's the trick I almost made
it by a just gotta get by this one
[Music]
that's a lot of death goodness oh no not
one ninety I have zero out of two gold
coins I have one of the gold coins
that's what it says for me I'm trusting
you it says I have one of two okay this
is my last one
alright this is it alright we've got
this where's the button
I did make it guys alright okay once
we're ready I've got it in the bag dude
you're so it's opening all right okay
[Laughter]
no that was amazing there if you come
back to the start mode I can open this
for you I'm gonna wait till you open it
first
I can't possibly mess that up that's the
end
[Laughter]
no you you are at the normal leg this is
[ __ ] this no guys it goes up yeah I made
it I think we all say [ __ ] it on this
one [ __ ] you just you just go - when you
- you go up more yeah you just gotta
jump yeah easy
alright easy top left
oh you turn the thing off oh oh it's
periodically uhh
that that's not what you want wooly baby
Wow wait you don't jump off the edge wid
all right you're right damn it
did I kill ya oh wait maybe now I don't
know I don't know where to oh this is
gonna be a challenge don't understand
you gotta like fall and jump I think or
- you just have to time your you have
like an air jump you just have to time
it right I'm going for it oh for God's
sake spikes over there now yeah just go
go you got it
see good you got it oh no wait why God
oh boy oh boy oh boy I think I need to
turn the air off for you to get the gym
alright turn the air off wait wait wait
okay see ya you can stand would I get in
there now you set the - I think the best
jump you jump and then - - double jump
right don't - - jump - I am confident
that you can do it bud I just want to
point out there's another button at the
end is there where below me like right
below me here it opens the wall on the
left okay so what do I got with the
double oh I got it I got it so we need
to come the air on we're gonna get the
other button the other button allows you
to fly over top of it and go in from
right here at the left hands open up
that line I'm going for it
okay when was it fully back yet I
thought open to wall it must
be the wind must be a problem so turn
that wind off I'm going for it dude I
get this right for some reason just die
every time all right leave the wind on
leave it on oh all right [ __ ] if you get
on top of that can you drop in between
the spike and the wall and just slide it
[Music]
just the three of us to play some more
bloody trip so really it just bothers me
not finishing up the level that's all
right I'll do it with you I guess okay
goodbye this hole that's not a hole yeah
but that look I get what you're saying
it looked like a thing why do I have to
do this that's the worst thing Wade I
didn't have to agree to join you oh you
sure did that was dumb yeah there we go
okay it's very simple oh my god
[Laughter]
stop laughing this your noises it's like
it's like a Japanese horn actress what
would you call that
hi no sin okay I don't know much I I
learned the different hint on henna cut
behind on henna and tie no no I was so
close oh my god this is impossible wait
why have we tried this oh I don't know
buddy
stop calling me buddy stop girl
everybody you never call me buddy all
right pal like that any better
all right friend oh that's worse
it's a Christian oh I just wish I were
dead
oh you know I did the slide I didn't do
anything I didn't do it I don't think
you slide there I don't agree with you
you you you brought me here and and I
you know cuz you made a good argument
with like the not finishing things out
I'm like a khaki how long could it take
without the others weighing me down I
might be able to do it but now I am down
buddy we got this you're right when you
right you right you right you haven't
even gotten halfway through it dude I
know okay I'm a slow slider you don't
slide yeah you don't slide you just pop
nope oh god that's a platform at the
bottom isn't it I'm an idiot you just
drop down
oh is that just a pizza platform at the
bottom oh my god wait I'm gonna remember
this remembered today I'm so experienced
between friends haven't eaten in a long
time oh yeah I saw I was a big mistake
yeah this platform did surprisingly are
not surprisingly actually it shouldn't
be any why oh my god is there one after
this please tell me this is the last one
is it the last was three there's three I
didn't tell you that to start no you
didn't know you didn't know you didn't
you said too fast you see the only
reason you can keep going is because you
you had food you have did I did I had a
great meal yeah you had food you had
food I have not had food
why oh if I booked it
you know once it won one of these days
someone's actually gonna make an album
of all your noises and that will be your
legacy like not my noises your noises
all your random weird wait isms that you
just so happened why you know when you
know cuz there won't be like children's
books anymore so it'd be like grandpa
Wade your childhood novel Grampy I don't
know why your kids are old too but how
what wait you have to go out I don't
okay that's not so bad
nice leaf Oh see the thing is the coins
in the other level the challenge level
it was gold for me that's weird they're
big both lift silver for me they're gold
for me maybe cuz I'm winning wait I
don't know mark there was a secret in
that level to open this pyramid I don't
care no we don't have a coin we can't
unlock it we do we got a coin early no
because it was this you said yourself it
was us uh uh it was uh it was uh mama
I'm ma ma ma ma ma Busa you said
yourself oh I see where this is a coin
but we I saw where it is it's right here
I don't have a coin did no I don't have
a cool I do you have a coin but yours
was silver you said oh yeah it is ha ha
we should go let's go where was it again
all right good yeah good good there's
the last one right that we got to find
the coin is our coin here no the other
coin was I already told you what I
already told you where the other coin
was oh where was the other corn was it
on that level the one that you know the
one that you said was silver for me it
was gold which meant that for I needed
to get it for some reason I'm the one
that the game I need to get the coins oh
my god whoa great
that's even better is this a boss is the
boss isn't it oh my god
there's TNT barrels I bet those die
yeah what was that okay okay how do you
T&T good question Wade great question
much like your other great questions I
don't have an answer kids wait questions
America you're right okay what do I do
this
TNT don't do anything I don't oh I know
what we do at the TNT we got to get it
to eat the TNT so we don't touch the TNT
until it's time to touch the TMT
I touched it too early
alright wait we got to work together on
this
[Laughter]
I touched it why okay listen this timing
stuff man
oh you can ride on it apparently you
ever just get so tired that you're just
like I could death could claim me and I
wouldn't actually feel anything oh yeah
I don't know how to time that how did we
time that right right on me right on me
yes I'm proud of you okay well there we
go oh he's almost dead don't get away
from me watch this
write it yes meet me oh come on why
would you do this wow this game is all
about timing apparently and we are good
at the whole timing thing
sorry I don't feel bad actually but I am
sorry come here come here come here come
here come here come here come here come
here come here come here
oh that was right there dude this is
rough all right here we go
you got this one yeah yeah that's two
for you none for me I feel bad but bad
Snickers it's not that's King Kent or
something oh I was too early on this one
it's okay it's okay it's okay what I'm
gonna get him I'm gonna get come for me
come on come for me come on yes oh I
think I did too but
I don't know how it wasn't really my
doing oh god I'm on a ball tease what
did I just say you're an a-hole tease I
don't know what that means I'm actually
kind of concerned about that one but you
know I'll let it I'll let it slide for
now oh there we go okay so if he hits it
it'll blow up right away okay good to
know
you know why that's a lot easier than
timing you can come here you okay why'd
you miss it yes
why do you don't worry I got this okay
oh I've got big worms to bribe my beef
what yeah weird great great good job
teamwork yeah
all right truce to leave still I don't
know how oh yeah we do I see it I'm
stealing it I'm stealing it yeah we done
are we done are we done no coin listen
we're only one level away from winning
man right I was selfish you're right I
was selfish food is like the ambrosia of
suck you're right
I think it was in level five I think
five was no was it three it was three
three get off the boat I think it was
three it was no was it four oh yeah why
not what was it for
no it was not for I think it was three
you're right mm-hmm
it was not three it was five five is the
one it was all right it was five yeah
it's this one I remember oh yeah it's
the duck under Hitler oh no no it's fine
cuz watch this see okay wait where was
the thing that we got to go forward to
go backwards oh it's down to the left
yeah well you gotta get the key though
I'll go get it no I mean I'll yeah I'll
get it yeah hang on just wait watch this
watch this move watch the scene you're
watching and I am safe see you just go
under it
all right so I did it I did it to get
you stay there no oh my god I'm sorry
you stay there you go back be careful
it's trap in there you're right
you right oh yeah wait I remember I
remember got it
so that was gold for you that was gold
for me yes I don't know why I'm the only
one that has gold coins but I've got it
let me finish the level though oh okay
just because in case that's part of it
why that time okay so it's a little it's
a little windy one that never works for
me sitting there okay it's a little
winky wonky on the time but watch this
move
see you're just go under it okay so we
got the gold coin I don't know where the
gold coin slot is until a coin silver
for me cuz you suck and he knows I'm
great and that's the only thing that's
the only qualification that you need for
it and if you suck and you know I'm
great then you don't need right all
right I know I'm right
you're right I think I'm right on this
one okay and I know where this goes
it's right here I've already got it dude
it's done done where's it's right there
go go go go go one thing yeah after this
this little exclamation point no we
didn't do the exclamation point last
time you can't make me do it you're
right we're gonna do two exclamation
points no what even is this okay oh I'll
go down I'll see what down is what's
this do
you know I don't know there's sparklies
above me there's a lot of buttons here
I'm gonna see what they do
button button oh wow Oh oh my god okay
one of those buttons kills me some other
button somewhere will kill me but I do
this for you can you go up oh you have
to be in there that's right okay uh-huh
okay
so go up there I'm like up and I'm gonna
send you up again yeah
okay can try up there now do not kill me
oh my god okay wait now now Idol send me
now you can send me up yeah you'll send
me and so I'll go in here now and now
you send me out this one yeah it's up
the arrows are like up and down up one
more good good good good now I'm welcome
go in here I can't raise it down go down
braise it down you got it you know what
I mean all right and I'm gonna slide
through here no no no no no no no Oh up
up up up up up one for now up another
okay okay now down one okay okay and
that should open yeah okay so all right
now oh oh no can it go out anymore
oh just don't touch the bottom all right
[Laughter]
what's the teleport it teleports that's
good I think we just leave yep hey easy
Brad
wait I'm done I'm so hungry thank you
are you gonna keep streaming no but I'm
gonna take us to this low before you go
great I don't want to see it because if
I see it I might have to do it all right
don't look oh that's bad
I don't know what these do man I have no
idea okay these this particle whoa did
you just take with us hi dude wait you
change the plot you change what
platforms are real exactly oh we know
that's lit up why is that lit up now oh
oh they're moving okay
no I freeze them oh I freeze them in
place okay oh I get it okay so um can
you climb up the ones that are spinning
over by the crystal over there that's
what I was thinking yeah I'm not sure
oh you're good you're good okay that's
good ah close why are we doing this I'm
so hungry
oh no why'd you agree to this I didn't
agree to this
okay oh geez oh I can't make that jump I
guess uh maybe I don't know maybe I
should come press the buttons and you
should do the jumping okay all right I
got it
oh [ __ ] oh yeah ow
mmm that green beans bad okay all right
that's good to know because I did not
know that green bean or green beam you
said bean oh you were hitting the beam
before okay
oh I'm not I'm up and we're stopping it
freeze it far far right all right okay
and then I'm gonna get up on this one
okay and then when this gets far right
freezer and okay it's that far enough
yeah I think it's really gonna be dicey
see if it's like an inch more that's
further not good enough dude you really
suck at this
I know I know I know what I didn't I
didn't jump on it that time it just did
it you don't have to jump on it good
there we go that's good
here we go nailed it yes nice one it was
a powerful
please tell me yes it wasn't top right I
don't think it is no don't left your
narrow above okay goodbye
all right good one no no we just need to
look at it we did world one exclamation
because we did set off the beacon I
remember that we did that we did it we
did it yeah we did it so we're good
well why isn't it lit up we did a dumb
it's lit up
yeah it's lit up they said we did it Oh
she'll double-check no I'm done we did
it
I'm out we could do it yeah look we got
two dots yeah we did it
all right well Marcy in 30 minutes so
you can do world 3 no I'm going home
goodbye No
farewell
[Music]